hello everyone and welcome to a couple
of games from the tata still challengers
that we are going to cover well i'm
going to show you briefly two of them
and the the the one that we are going to
cover is um arjun nergaisi versus surya
shekar ganguly as i checked out all the
games and i thought this one was the
nicest to show uh uh well since it's a
very nice game but also since ganguly is
the highest rated opponent in the
tournament so i i thought it'd be
fitting to show this one and as you know
erigacy won the tournament very nicely
uh i i think two full points ahead of
everyone else uh it's an incredible
incredible achievement uh but uh okay uh
before we check out this one i would
just like to briefly show you this is uh
the position from his game against max
varmadam uh eddie he had the black
pieces here and max tried a a very
interesting queen sacrifice he played a5
uh and eddie gracie played bishop to a6
so he attacked the rook on f1 offering
the knight here which looks really
really weird but this saw the game
continued uh so a captures on b6 was
played and now not root cap bishop
captures an f1 but rather rook the c8
now with the thread of bishop captures
an f2 check and picking up the queen and
here you have to play queen to d1 and
then we go uh into well then the game
just continues with whatever black
decides probably queen captures and b6
puts more pressure defends the bishop
and so on uh but here rook captures an
a6 was played max sacrificed the queen
and ergasi of course goes for it bishop
captures on f2 king captures and now
rook captures on c2 uh b captures an a7
now a beautiful pass pawn is created but
here comes knight b6 so the a8 square is
nicely defended and after king to g1 uh
you have to get your king to safety and
now comes queen to c8 and this is not a
problem the rook is attacked and uh well
you could grab the knight and it seems
like black is only going for the bishop
on c1 but uh arigaisi has a different
plan after rook captures on b6 queen to
c5 check was played the king did not
hide
deep enough
and after king to h1 just queen captures
on b6 and of course it's a completely
winning for black there's no way to take
advantage of the pawn you're going to
win the pawn let's say knight f3 we're
going to play queen captures on a7 and
let's say bishop to f4 uh
as the game did continue rogue captures
on b2 and the white really doesn't have
all that much to play for here so that's
uh the the game against max very very
nicely done and here is a game uh
erigasi versus daniel darda we also
checked out the game darda played if you
remember that brilliant miniature uh
against paulina chuvalova and uh here
knight to f5 was played and now it it
looks like uh you could capture the
knight with the bishop or the pawn uh
but that's uh uh definitely not
suggested so in the game knight knight e
the g8 was played and now queen to g5 it
gets just uh brings more pieces into the
attack and here uh not g captures an f5
but bishop captures an f5 was played but
even this is completely lost for black
now so just to show you the attack e
captures on f5 now comes rook c to c8
and now bishop to e4 putting more
pressure on the g6 square so black
captures here we have knight captures
and now queen to e7 offering a queen
trade and while white could start with f
captures and g6 white says nope we can
trade queens and that's perfectly fine
this is completely winning for white and
indeed it is there's really no no
defense g6 is hanging too much so after
captures and knight captures with chuck
king to g7f captures on g6 and now you
really don't have a good way of
recapturing because if you capture with
the f1 knight here a nice fork picks up
the rook if you capture with the king
another knight the e6 opens up a
discovery from the rook picks up the
rook on v8 so here knight to the h6 was
played but now comes a brilliant
finisher g captures an f7 rook to d7
preparing to pick up the pawn here but
now knight to e4 with check king f8 and
now a temporary exchange sacrifice rook
to g8 to check knight captures ng8 and
now f captures on g8 with queen king
captures and now we have uh set up the
fork knight f6 check and that's it king
of seven knight captures and of course
there there's nothing to be done here
but the game was over i think even
before the rook was captured so those
were some of the nice games that i uh
decided to include in this video
although all of them are super enjoyable
but this is the one that we are going to
cover in detail like i said incredibly
strong opponent and the game is very
enjoyable so let's dive straight into it
uh arjun
with the white pieces opens with e4 uh
we have e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and
the bishop to c4
we have bishop to c5 the joko piano is
on the board and uh here we have c3 now
unfortunately we have the joko piano we
have knight to f6 and now d4 y strikes
in the center right away we have e
capture sunday d4 and now e5 advancing
the pawn to attack the knight uh if you
guys remember we mentioned a couple of
times that the famous greco attack is
the sea captures bishop for chicken
knight to c3 starting the greco attack
but the the greco attack is not nearly
as powerful as it was uh a century ago
so people no longer play it so here we
have e5 and now we have d5 d5 is the
only good reply here for black and you
should remember this if you
play this with black because everything
else will just uh you know you're just
gonna run into a lot of trouble so that
should be five and now knight to e4 so
these are these are all top top moves
this is all very standard theory c
capture sunday for bishop to b6 and now
knight to c3 putting pressure on the
knight on e4 so black castles and now
bishop to e3 again nothing out of the
ordinary here uh here is already a very
interesting uh idea bishop to g4 and f5
are are well top moves here in this
position but here again we place f6 and
it's a it's a bit of a different idea
because it's like f5 you could capture a
captures on f6 e even though okay this
is not alpha sum but the position would
be the same but also it means that you
are not uh protecting your knights twice
so what happens if white just captures
an e4 that's also very interesting uh
the idea is that after the captures
we're going to play bishop captures on
c6 and after b captures knight to d2 and
now it looks like
we've done great but the problem is that
we do not
capture on d4 we're not interested in
that we continue pushing f5 f4 and uh
well you're in a lot of trouble here as
white so instead after this f6 move uh
continues with e captures on f6 uh and
now we have knight captures and c3 b
captures in c three and queen captures
an f6 so black gets a lot of pressure
here along the f file uh and also his
bishop and knight are nicely placed but
the c3 pawn guarding the d4 pawn really
makes it uh
not all that easy for black to
uh
do anything along this
line so probably we're gonna see the
knight will move c6 will be played the
bishop will be shifted to this diagonal
and so on
so here it castles by irigase and now
bishop to g4 adding a third attacker to
the knight on f3 so bishop back to e2
only move
and now bishop captures an f3 you could
also consider some developing move or
something like that but okay here we
have bishop captures and f3 bishop
captures uh and now rook 8 d8
and now we have bishop to e2 shifting
the bishop over to d3 and interestingly
so far all of these moves have been
played but now comes knight to a5 and it
is now as of move 16 that we have a
completely new game uh so what uh what
can you do here well yeah it is starts
off very strong he plays a4 and here he
says
if you were ever considering placing
this knight on c4 that's no longer
happening the the thing is if if knight
c4 now we can just capture it and play
a5 and the bishop is trapped so
you know
there's even that so here c6 this is
what we were planning we want to shift
the bishop to c7 grab hold of this
diagonal uh we have bishop to d3 and now
bishop to c7 so both players have nicely
developed their pieces but if you look
at the
white's bishop pair it is definitely
stronger than black's bishop and the
knight on a5 because the knight on a5
isn't really doing all that much for the
moment so here we have queen to g4
bringing the queen in into the attack
queen h5 can also be considered just
going after h7 but um that can easily be
prevented so irrigacy has a different
plan uh we have rook d to e8 now and
rook a to e1 of course so we need to
activate our rooks now comes bishop to
d8 as uh
you you really don't have uh maybe a
better move here with black you just
want to play queen h4 and maybe try and
trade off the queens so g3 preventing
this and now comes queen to f3 and this
was the move that
was uh just a bit too much now you have
to play knight to c4 bring the knight
into the game of course the bishop
therefore will be played we're gonna
try and keep our bishop there but after
queen to f3 that's a problem because now
queen h3 comes with tempo of course we
are threatening queen captures on h7 or
bishop captures depending on what black
plays
and now there is no good move here for
black g6 was played but now it's um
completely winning for white and it
really shows you the power of the bishop
pair so feel free to pause the video
this is only the first pause the video
moment
so try and figure out how to win this
with white while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
the well
brilliant bishop maneuvering and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's bishop e2 a very sneaky move
but the idea is we want to bring the
bishop to g4 and then to e6 hopefully
and there's not all that much black can
do about this so congratulations to
every everyone who found this now in the
game queen to f5 was played but we're
gonna check out what happens if queen to
f7 then the rook is just stuck on f8
we're going to win the rook and that's
it then white wins and also incredibly
interesting is queen to f6 we also have
to consider this because now we play
bishop to h6 okay now the rook has the
f7 square so we're going to save the
rook but again there's the problem uh
the rook can never go to e7 because then
a bishop to g5 will just be too strong
at some point uh for for the moment it's
not defended but that's why we play f4
and now you can't play this because
bishop to g5 will just be crushing so
you're going to have to play something
but there's not all that much to play
for example
if you make a move just bishop g4 is
enough to win the game we have too much
control over the e6 square and even
after this gets traded off still bishop
is coming to e6 and that's just uh
that's just it there's no playing this
so uh actually what happened in the game
was queen to f5 gangly offered a queen
trade but now comes bishop the g4 and
this is playing right into our hand
queen f6 and now bishop to f4 uh this
bishop to f4 is uh uh well
maybe the second best idea as we don't
want to allow knight to c4 so you could
play bishop to d7 right away now
everything will be played with tempo and
after rook d7 now bishop to f4 now we're
really just you know leaving black
without the move and now if knight the
c4 is played now we just play rook
captures on e7 and after queen captures
we can play bishop to h6 and well
there's not all that much you can play
here again bishop to e6
incredible threat not much you can do
about this so instead bishop to f4 was
played
this is also sufficient but now okay
maybe knight to c4 is a little stronger
here now but okay in the game h5 was
played and now bishop to d7 attacking
the rook so rook captures rook captures
and now king to h7 uh and now comes rook
to e6 attacking the queen so queen to f7
and again the position is completely
winning for white but there is only one
move that wins this game and it's not an
easy one to spot you really have to you
know shuffle your pieces around so feel
free to pause the video for the second
time and win this game with this
brilliant idea while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on uh you know being
a great shuffler of pieces and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is rook to d6 this is the only
winning move again not an easy one to
find maybe bishop to e2 was a little
easier
but here you play rook here bishop here
and the rook here and then you're
winning and there's nothing black can do
about this uh here queen to e7 was
played just uh
uh you know trying something maybe rook
to e1 can be played but they just bishop
the e6 and there's no no way to defend
this but uh rook to d7 is coming so
you're gonna uh
lose the queen uh so the thing is if you
move the king let's say king a chad just
bishop e5 check and look at the the the
impressive bishop player here this is
just unstoppable king has to go back now
rook d7 again picks up the queen so in
the game rook captures and f4 was played
hoping that um uh gazi will capture the
rook uh but it just rooked to d7 and now
again the queen is captured we have rook
to f6 rook captures on e7 bishop
captures and now bishop to c8 and okay
black has a bishop knight in the rook
against the queen and bishop but it is
um
definitely not compensation enough so
here rook to d6 uh but now g4 we want to
bust open the king side and we'll
try and get some checks against the
black king so knight to c4 finally the
knight rejoins the game g captures on h5
g captures and the bishop to e6 now we
can capture but uh maybe bishop to e6
first we don't want to allow this rogue
back into the game so king g7 we have f
for now uh we could also play uh uh
other things but it's uh after f5 that's
just game so knight's the d2 trying to
get the white to go for this check maybe
then we can pick up the bishop uh but
eddie gates just plays f5 he says that's
not happening and now uh that's pretty
much it the queen captures and h5 will
be played doesn't really matter what
black plays rook captures on e6 was
played but now f captures an e6 knight
to e4 and queen captures an h5 we have
knight to g5 preventing queen f queen f7
now comes queen to e8 and now you're
just gonna pick up everything on the
queen side and that's too easy of a
victory so king f6 queen d7 and he was
in this position on move 42 that surya
shekar ganguly resigned the game uh as
there is nothing more uh to be done here
so that's the the third game that we we
enjoyed uh from the event um like i said
all the games are super enjoyable so you
guys if you want you can check them out
by yourself and you you will not be
sorry so these are the standings after
uh all of the runs have been played as
you can see here yes he won the
tournament with two full points again uh
ahead of everyone else uh 10 and a half
uh out of 13 and interestingly uh his
coach posted on twitter that before the
tournament even started he sent him a
message that he would like to have a 10
and a half out of 13 uh that he doesn't
even care all that much about winning
the tournament that it would be more
important for him to get 10 and a half
out of 13. so if someone gets more uh
then okay he played a brilliant
tournament
but that that's what he was going for
and that's what he achieved which is
incredibly interesting uh because in the
last round game against maurizi uh the
game was pretty much a draw for for a
very long time and then he was able to
win that uh drawing game you know just
completely completely
incredible performance in this
tournament so really incredible stuff i
very much look forward to seeing him in
the tata still masters next year and
okay now you've seen that uh pragernanda
uh won the challengers last year and now
uh he he didn't well he played a great
tournament but it wasn't like in the in
the maybe upper half of the tournament
standings so you might be thinking how
will uh arjun ergaisi do uh in the
masters next year well we can also check
out uh some of his results from the
previous tournaments as that's uh well
uh
all just as incredible so these are the
standings from the tata steel chess
india uh edition and here you can see
that he won first place with a full
point ahead and ahead of lavon
uh pragananda and david uh so that's
incredible uh in itself then with five
points you have uh kart kin and uh sam
shanklin matsulu the quang liam adiban
and vaishali uh so also crushed the
tournament completely and what i think
could be an even more impressing
impressive result than actually winning
the tata still challengers uh is his
performance at the
85th tal memorial that was played in
riga it was the lindoris abbey chess
tournament where after uh 18 rounds of
incredible blitz chess he won third
place or maybe a shared second with
fabiano carwana uh there were over a
hundred players there and it was really
incredible but look at the look at the
names here uh sherchenko won the
tournament we've checked out i think one
of or two games uh from this event but
we did not cover the event all that much
so uh karwana and erigasi uh with 13 and
a half then you have martirosian david
navarro jeffrey daniel dubois levon arun
petersville or samuel savion
so those are
those are all just monsters and you can
see how well uh erigacy did so he is
improving at an incredible rate and uh a
lot of people are saying that he is
currently the strongest young player in
the world as he is only 18 years old
okay okay uh if you consider uh just
raiding then no no one can say anything
against alireza he is already 2800 but
even with his vast improvement um
alireza was already in the top top 10
before he improved to to 2800 uh whereas
erigasi he just uh you know uh
jumped like 50 places in in in the in
the standings and i think he is now uh i
don't want to lie to you so i'm gonna
check um let me just check this yeah
he's currently number 80 in the world
and he he jumped 54 uh 54
places in in in the standings in in
classical time format so really
incredible and uh well i i just can't
wait to see what he does next and uh how
he will do next year in the tata still
masters
uh and also yeah i know you guys were
requesting some more games so uh
probably i will show his game uh from
the lindori sabi against fabiano caruana
as that one was requested quite a lot if
you guys have any of your own favorites
do do share i might
show even more uh so yeah that's the
game or rather the games hope you guys
enjoyed that i would like to wish a very
happy birthday to taz uh and i would
like to thank yuri rochenko of a fun
paul and amir maron for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it uh as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing uh well to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
checking out on whatever else is
happening in the chess world uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day